We're on problem 148.
What is the lowest integer
that is the sum of three
different primes, each
greater than 20?
So it's the lowest integer, so
we essentially just have to
find the three primes
above 20.
So let's see, 21 isn't
a prime, 22 isn't a
prime, 23 is a prime.
24, no, 25, no, 26,
no, 27, 28, nope.
29, that's prime.
30 isn't, 31 is.
31 plus 29 is 60 plus 23 is
83, and that is choice E.
I hope I haven't missed any
primes, no, I don't think I
have. 24, 25, 26, 27, 28,
I think I got all
the primes in there.
What is the lowest integer of
the sum of three different
primes, each greater than 20?
Yep, that's the answer, E.
Problem 149.
The average of 6, 8, and 10
equals-- so the average of 6,
8, and 10, so first of all,
what's the average
of 6, 8, and 10?
Well, let's just do it.
6 plus 8 plus 10.
You could immediately see the
average is going to be 8,
because you have 8 in the
middle, and both of these
numbers are 2 away from it.
But that divided by 3 is
equal to 24 divided by
3 is equal to 8.
And that's equal to the average
of 7 plus 9 plus x
over 3, so that tells us to
multiply both sides of this
equation by 3, that says
that 24 is equal to--
what's 7 plus 9?
That's 16 plus x.
Subtract 16 from both sides,
you get x is equal to 8.
Choice C.
And you could have said, OK, 7
and 9 or both half-- 8 is in
the middle, and they have to
average 8, so you might have
just been able to eyeball it and
say 8, but it didn't take
that much math, it's not that
much of a shortcut.
Problem 150.
If x is equal to minus 1, then x
to the fourth minus x to the
third plus x squared, all
of that over x minus
1 is equal to what?
x to the fourth is 1.
x to the third is minus 1, but
then we're going to minus
that, so this whole thing is
going to be plus 1, and x
squared is plus 1.
Negative 1 squared is 1.
And you have minus 1 minus 1.
So in the numerator you have
1, 2, 3, in the denominator
you have minus 2.
Let's put the minus out
front, minus 3/2.
That's choice A.
Problem 151.
A toy store regularly
sells all stock at a
discount of 20% to 40%.
If an additional 25% were
deducted from the discount
price during a special sale,
what would be the lowest
possible price of a toy costing
$16 before any discount?
So we want to discount the
$16 as much as possible.
So they say they're normally
discounting 20% to 40%, so if
you want to discount this as
much as possible, you want to
discount this by 40%.
So if you discount this by 40%,
that's the same thing as
saying it's going to be equal to
60% of its original price.
So this would be the price after
being discounted by 40%,
and then we would discount
by another 25%.
Actually, I think it's easier
to go the other way.
Well, let's just
do it this way.
So we discount it by
another 25%, so we
multiply it by 3/4 again.
If you discount by 25%, the
price is going to be 3/4 of
its original price.
Actually, let's do
it as fractions.
Fractions are always easier.
60% percent of your
price is 3/5.
If you discount by 2/5, or 40%,
that's the same thing as
multiplying by 3/5, and
then we're going
to multiply by 3/4.
Set 25%.
If you're discounting by 25%,
that's the same thing as being
worth 75% of your
original price.
So what does that get us?
16 divided by 4, 4, you get a 1,
and then you have 4 times 3
times 3, 4 times 9 is 36, over
5, which is equal to-- 5 goes
into 36 7 and 1/5.
So $7.20.
And that's choice B.
Problem 152.
The shaded portion of the
rectangular lot shown above
represents a flowerbed.
OK, so let me draw this
rectangular lot.
They drew this shaded portion
something like that, and I can
even color it in.
So they say the shaded portion
of the rectangular lot shown
above represents a flowerbed.
If the area of the bed is 24
square yards, and x is equal
to y plus 2, so they tell us
this side right here is x,
which now they're telling
us is equal to y plus 2.
And this right here is going
to be equal to y.
Then z equals what? z is
this side right there.
So if this area is 24, that
tells us that x times y
times 1/2 is 24.
That's the area of that.
So 1/2xy is equal to 24.
Or you can even say that
xy is equal to 48.
We know what xy is.
We can just substitute for
x, so we get y plus
2, that's x, right?
X is equal to y plus 2 times
y is equal to 48.
And so we get y squared plus
2y is equal to 48.
Or y squared plus 2y minus
48 is equal to 0.
We could factor this
quadratic.
What two numbers when you
multiply by minus 48, and you
add you get plus 6?
So y plus 8 times y minus 6 is
equal to 0, 8 times minus 6 is
minus 48, and then 8 minus 6 is
plus 2, so y could be equal
to minus 8 or plus 6, right?
Whatever numbers make either
of these equal to zero.
Well, we can't have a negative
distance, so y is not equal to
minus 8, so y is equal to 6.
y is equal to 6, x
is equal to 8.
Now, we can just confirm, 6
times 8 is 48 times 1/2 is
equal to 24.
And now we can use the
Pythagorean theorem
to figure out z.
So we'll get z squared
is equal to 36.
That's y squared plus 64,
which is x squared, so z
squared is equal to 100.
z is equal to 10.
Choice E.
Problem 153.
Jack is now 14 years older than
Bill, so Jack is equal to
Bill plus 14.
If in 10 years Jack will be
twice as old as Bill, so 2
times Bill's age, how old
will Jack be in 5 years?
So they want to know j plus 5.
That's how old Jack will
be in 5 years.
So let's just try to
solve for Jack.
This top equation tells us that
Bill is equal to Jack
minus 14, and then
we can substitute
this in for Bill here.
So then this equation will
become Jack plus 10 is equal
to 2 times Jack minus 14.
So Jack plus 10 is equal to
2 times Jack minus 28.
If we subtract Jack from both
sides, you get 10 is equal to
Jack minus 28.
We can add 28 to both
sides, and you get
38 is equal to Jack.
So that's how old Jack is now.
He's 38 years old.
So how old is Jack going
to be in 5 years?
38 plus 5 is equal
to 43 years old.
And I've clearly made a mistake,
because that's not
one of the options.
So let's see where I'm
made an error.
So Jack is now 14 years
older than Bill.
Fair enough.
So in 10 years, Jack will be
twice-- oh, I see my mistake.
He's going to be twice
as old as Bill is
going to be in 10 years.
That was a bone-headed
mistake.
So let me clear all of this.
That was a bad mistake.
I shouldn't have made it.
I'm lucky that they didn't have
what I put down as one of
the choices, and I would've
gotten it wrong.
All right.
So we know that in 10 years,
Jack is going to be 2 times
what Bill is going to
be in 10 years.
That was my mistake.
So now let's see
what we can do.
We'll use that same information
up there, so Bill
is equal to Jack minus 14.
Substitute that information
here, so we get Jack plus 10
is equal to 2 times Jack minus
14, instead of Bill, plus 10.
So you get Jack plus 10 is
equal to 2 times Jack.
Let's see, minus 14 plus 10,
that's minus 4, so Jack plus
10 is equal to 2 times
Jack minus 8.
Let's subtract Jack
from both sides.
10 is equal to Jack minus 8.
Let's add 8 to both sides.
You get 18 is equal to Jack.
So that's how old Jack is
right now, he's 18.
So in five years, Jack is going
to be 18 plus 5, which
is 23 years old, choice D.
And I'm out of time.
See you in the next video.